liebe kolleginnen liebe kollegen
herzlich willkommen in der
bundespressekonferenz zu unserer
wöchentlichen wohnanlage dazu begrüße
ich ganz herzlich
bundesgesundheitsminister jens spahn
herzlich willkommen an sie daneben hat
platz genommen professor dr lothar
wieler präsident des robert koch
instituts und ganz außen von mir aus
gesehen rechts hat platz genommen
professor dr.med steffen weber carstens
leidender oberarzt an der charité und
koordinator für die versorgung der kogit
19 patienten in berlin
und bevor wir zu den statements kommen
und so übliche vorbemerkung für die
zuschauer die uns live sehen und
vielleicht nicht wissen was die
bundespressekonferenz ist die
bundespressekonferenz ist keine
institution der bundesregierung sondern
ein unabhängiger verein von
journalistinnen und journalisten die in
berlin über die bundespolitik berichten
unsere aufgabe ist es pressekonferenzen
zu veranstalten und unsere
mitgliedschaft damit die gelegenheit für
fragen zu bieten und dazu kommen wir
dann gleich als erstes hat das wort
ersparen bitteschön er lieber erst ende
war nie meine damen und herren diese
woche sind wir einen tag früher in der
woche am donnerstag bereits bei ihnen
das hat terminliche gründe weil morgen
zur gleichen zeit der deutsche bundestag
ja das infektionsschutzgesetz beraten
wird
aber es ist in gewisser weise auch
symbolisch denn jeder tag zählt gerade
in dieser schwierigen lage
vor einer woche haben wir professor
wieder und ich hier die lage als sehr
ernst beschrieben
wir haben gesagt dass die relativ
niedrigeren zahlen in den tagen nach
ostern kein grund zur entwarnung sein
leider hat sich diese warnung bestätigt
die infektionszahlen sind zu hoch und
sie steigen weiter
die lage auf vielen intensivstationen
wird täglich kritischer die
eindringlichen appelle von
intensivmedizinern sollten wir hören
unser ernst nehmen übrigens auch die
hinweise der pflegekräfte und aller
beschäftigten auf den intensivstationen
dass sie in vielen regionen in vielen
städten in vielen kliniken in
deutschland mittlerweile seit vielen
monaten und der sehr starker
dauerbelastung stehen deswegen ist mein
klarer ab
in dieser aktuellen situation auch an
die länder es ist gut dass wir mit der
notbremse per bundesgesetz bald eine
einheitliche und nachvollziehbare
regelung haben aber wir sollten nicht
darauf warten bis der bundestag nächste
woche dieses gesetz beschlossen hat ich
habe bereits vor einer woche gesagt dass
es zusätzliche massnahmen braucht und
wir konsequent handeln müssen die zeit
drängt und bereits jetzt haben alle auch
die möglichkeit schon zu handeln man
muss nicht auf dieses bundesgesetz
wachten impfen und testen alleine reicht
nicht um die dritte welle zu brechen
dafür braucht es entschiedenes handeln
und so schwer das ist weitere
einschränkungen
warum das notwendig ist lässt sich an
wenigen daten zeigen zeigen wir liegen
bei einer sieben tage incidents von über
140 die zahl der gemeldeten corona toten
innerhalb der letzten 24 stunden ist auf
etwa 300 gestiegen und das ist die
härteste währung in dieser pandemie der
blick auf die klinische situation auf
die intensivstation weil das ist
wirklich eindeutig und eigentlich gar
nicht zu missinterpretiert
die zahl der intensivpatienten mit
kuwait 19 liegt wieder bei fast 5000 und
der professor weber carstens wird das
sicherlich gleich auch aus der täglichen
situation berichten können und
intensivmediziner rechnen damit dass wir
ende des monats also in zwei wochen
sogar 6000 cupid 19 patienten auf den
intensivstationen werden versorgen
müssen
das heißt schon jetzt können wir absehen
dass ohne einen stopp dieser entwicklung
unser gesundheitssystem an den rand
seiner kapazität gelangen wird
deswegen habe ich gerade auch noch mal
gesagt die situation auf den
intensivstationen in den kliniken ist
einer der ganz entscheidenden parameter
weil eines unserer hauptziele das
hauptziel in dieser pandemie ist ja eine
überlastung des gesundheitssystems zu
vermeiden
das ist die priorität gewesen seit über
zwölf monaten und ist es bis heute
und ist es bis heute gelungen in den
wellen in all den schwierigen
situationen ja und der stadt
belastung ist es gelungen eine
überlastung zu vermeiden und das gilt es
auch jetzt zu erreichen und das was wir
jetzt möglicherweise versäumen recht
sich in zwei drei wochen genauso wie
sich jetzt recht was vor zwei drei
wochen nicht entschieden wurde
das alles sind keine neuen erkenntnisse
das weiß ich aber wir wissen aus dem
herbst was passiert wenn wir nicht rasch
genug handeln
die lage ist umso ernüchternder als dass
es bund ländern und den ärztinnen und
ärzten gemeinsam gelungen ist
flächendeckend es kapazitäten aufzubauen
und die impfkampagne deutlich zu
beschleunigen
es gibt inzwischen über 15.000 stellen
in deutschland in denen es den
bürgerinnen und bürgern möglich ist
kostenlos ein bürger test zu bekommen
und innerhalb von wenigen wochen
entstanden nachdem der bund die kosten
übernommen den rahmen gesetzt hat und
die zahl der täglichen impfungen
erreicht nun regelmäßig nicht täglich
aber regelmäßig eine größenordnung
zwischen 500.000 und 700.000 gestern
wurden 558.000 menschen in deutschland
geimpft damit wohl 19,8 millionen
impfungen gegeben 14,6 millionen
erstimpfungen das heißt 17,6 prozent der
deutschen haben mindestens eine impfung
aber leider kommen diese fortschritte
durch das aktuelle infektionsgeschehen
nicht so zum tragen wie man es sich
wünschen würde
denn gegen ein exponentielles wachstum
der infektion kann man nicht an impfen
oder antesten
das zeigen die erfahrungen auch in
ländern die bereits noch mehr impfungen
als wir in deutschland haben geben
können größere teile der bevölkerung
haben impfen können selbst in den usa in
kanada in chile steigen die fallzahlen
sind teilweise neue einschränkungen
notwendig das sollte uns ein mahnendes
beispiel sein wir müssen erst das
infektionsgeschehen in den griff
bekommen und die zahlen senken und dann
können wir test gestützt öffnen auch
mehr öffnungs perspektive geben als vor
sechs oder zwölf monaten eben weil wir
deutlich mehr
tests und testangebote haben und damit
können wir eine brücke bauen ist das
impfen den entscheidenden unterschied
macht aber dafür müssen wir zuerst diese
welle brechen mit weiteren
einschränkungen das ist nicht schön aber
notwendig danke herr spahn professor
viele ja gut morgen meine damen kann
wir alle wissen wir befinden uns in der
dritten welle und die lage in den
krankenhäusern spitzt sich teilweise
dramatisch zu und wird uns auch noch
härter treffen als in der zweiten welle
darauf gehe ich gleich noch mal im
detail ein klar ist wir müssen jetzt
handeln jetzt auf allen ebenen und
natürlich auch besonders auf der ebene
der entscheider
wir müssen unsere kontakte jetzt
reduzieren infektionsketten jetzt
unterbrechen und damit menschenleben und
die gesundheit von vielen retten
ja es gibt fortschritte aktuell sind
mehr als 17 prozent der bundesdeutschen
mindestens einmal geimpft dass wir beim
impfen vorankommen das ist sehr gut das
ist sogar fundamental wichtig aber es
werden eben noch viele mehrere monate
auf ihre impfung warten müssen
darunter und auch kinder und wenn wir
uns die situation anschauen wie sie
jetzt ist und zwar ganz nüchtern und
sachlich
der großteil der bevölkerung ist eben
nicht geimpft und wir haben es weiterhin
mit hohen fallzahlen zu tun
aktuell liegt die sieben tages inzidenz
bei über 160 400.000 und in fast allen
landkreisen gestern waren es von 412
deutschen landkreisen 403 ist die
inzidenz über 50 pro 100000 die meisten
neuerkrankungen finden übrigens bei den
15 bis 49 jährigen statt
aber selbst bei den über 90 jährigen
steigt die fallzahl wieder die
todeszahlen stagnieren in den letzten
zwei bis drei wochen aber sie gehen
nicht mehr zurück die fallzahlen meine
damen und herren die neben nicht etwa zu
weil mehr getestet wird
denn dann würden wir ja nicht erwarten
dass der anteil der positiven pcr test
ergebnisse zunimmt
tatsächlich nimmt er aber zu und der
lage in der letzten woche bei über zwölf
prozent
und tatsächlich nur für momentan nur
etwa die hälfte
der vorhandenen kapazität zur testung
für pcr darum möchte ich hier nochmals
appellieren an die hausärztinnen und
hausärzte bitte testen sie alle
patienten die symptome haben mit pcr wer
halt mittlerweile viele befunde aus den
laboren die uns einen überblick über die
besorgniserregenden varianten
verschaffen und hier können wir
verlässlich sagen dass b 11 7
die variante die ja deutlich
ansteckender ist inzwischen einen anteil
von 90 prozent ausmacht also wie
befürchtet und wie vorhergesehen nimmt
sie weiter zu aber jetzt da wir mal
einen blick auf unsere krankenhäuser und
intensivstationen und ich bin sehr froh
dass der biber carstens hier ist der
noch mal aus erster hand ihnen gleich
berichten wird wie der die wahrheit der
alltag auf diesen stationen ist
in deutschland sind etwa sechs von zehn
patienten die aufgrund einer schweren
ansteckenden atemwegsinfektion im
krankenhaus behandelt werden akten
momentan cupid 19 patienten sechs von
zehn und unter den patienten die
aufgrund ihrer atemwegserkrankung
intensivmedizinisch behandelt werden das
sind es knapp neun von zehn in unseren
akutkrankenhäusern werden aktuell ca
4700 patienten intensivmedizinisch
behandelt und diese zahl nimmt jeden tag
zu und die höchste stufe der
intensivmedizinischen behandlung die
sogenannte extrakorporale membran oxigin
irungu genannt oder umgangssprachlich
auch die sogenannte künstliche lunge
die wird immer häufiger benötigt mit eco
behandeln die ärzte patienten mit einem
akuten lungenversagen
meine damen und herren wenn wir hier
sitzen sind acht von zehn patienten die
aktuell in deutschland an der ecke sind
mit 19 infiziert acht von zehn
und es gibt also immer weniger ecmo
behandlungsplätze und das liegt unter
anderem daran dass auch vermehrt jüngere
patienten und patientinnen
intensivmedizinisch behandelt werden und
in einigen regionen müssen noch sehr
lange transportwege zur nächsten freien
admob platz in kauf genommen werden dazu
kommt dass immer mehr intensivstation
melden
das ihren betrieb einschränken mussten
zb aufgrund von personalmangel
wir erhalten gerade so viele
betriebseinschränkungen meldungen über
das register wie zum höhepunkt der
zweiten welle
wir können jetzt schon in einigen
städten und ballungszentren beobachten
dass es vorübergehend keine freien
intensivbetten mehr gibt und das in
einer situation in der wir ja damit
rechnen müssen dass in den kommenden
wochen noch mehr schwer kranke patienten
intensivmedizinisch behandelt werden
müssen da ja die fallzahlen steigen
das wissen wir nun seit monaten dass das
die logische konsequenz ist also müssen
zwei dinge geschehen und zwar rasch das
elektro programm muss deutlich reduziert
werden in allen krankenhäusern es sollte
nur noch ein eingeschränkter
regelbetrieb stattfinden um die intensiv
kapazitäten bestmöglich zu schonen wir
bald brauchen werden und stabile
patienten sollten aus regionen mit
akutem intensivbetten mangel rechtzeitig
in weniger betroffenen region verlegt
werden damit verhindern wir dass für die
noch kommenden schweren co at 19 fälle
keine intensivbetten mehr zur verfügung
stehen oder andere patienten überhastet
verlegt werden müssen
ich weiß patienten verlegungen in andere
regionen sind einschneidende maßnahmen
für die betroffenen aber auch für die
angehörigen aber wir müssen eine
bestmögliche versorgung garantieren
und hier müssen wir alle solidarisch
zusammenstehen und eben auch über stadt-
und landesgrenzen hinaus denken und dann
kann die lage in den krankenhäusern und
den intensivstationen ist dramatisch und
wenn sie auf die zahl der
neuerkrankungen todesfälle
intensivmedizinische behandlung aber
auch genesung anschauen
betrachten wir ein gewisser weise aber
nur die eine seite des coop 19 leidens
auch die sogenannten genesenen müssen
wir ja differenziert betrachten denn
viele leiden ja nach ihrer akuten
infektion noch wochen und monate lang an
gesundheitlichen schäden an dem
sogenannten cupid 19
nach aktuellen studien aus deutschland
ist das etwa einer von zehn die
wissenschaft wird hier noch
viele fragen beantworten müssen in den
kommenden folgen ja es gibt viele offene
fragen aber das heißt doch nicht dass
wir das einfach nicht beachten können
im gegenteil bedeutet es doch dass wir
vorsichtig sein müssen und zwar
besonders vorsichtig bei unsicheren
datenlage gilt dort das vorsichtsprinzip
den kurven 19 könnte viele von uns lange
treffen und ich denke dafür sollten uns
doch alle schützen
es gibt also ganz viele gründe warum wir
die infektionszahlen runterbringen
müssen hierfür brauchen wir jetzt die
umsetzung der wirksamen und bekannten
strategien die kennen wir doch alle
und ich appelliere nochmals an alle
entscheidungsträger wir brauchen jetzt
doch mal eine drastische kontakt
reduktion jetzt die dritte welle brechen
dann mit kontrollierten konzepten
parallel partiell öffnen und
kontinuierlich weiter impfen damit wir
genügend menschen geschützt haben und
dann meine damen und herren dann kommen
wir zur kontrolle kurve dann können wir
kontrollieren das ist unsere gemeinsame
aufgabe wissen sie stellen sich vor sie
fahren über enge straßen in den
dolomiten ist es kurvenreich und an
einer seite ist ein steiler abhang jeder
weiß in dieser kurve kann ich noch mit
30 fahren wenn ich hier mit einer
geschwindigkeitsbeschränkung von 100
rein fahre dann ist das lebensgefährlich
man kommt nämlich von der straße ab und
ehrlich gesagt hilft dann auch gar keine
notbremse und ich weiß dass sich viele
menschen seit langem täglich unter
erschwerten bedingungen an der pandemie
bekämpfung beteiligen indem sie kontakte
reduzieren den abstand halten
elian regeln beachten und nasenschutz
zahlen und natürlich auch wo immer
möglich lüften wenn sie im innenraum ist
und sich vor allem offen lassen und in
betrieben auch regelmäßig an testungen
teilnehmen dafür kann ich allen nur
danken es ist nämlich der weg raus aus
dieser pandemie aber jetzt erwarte ich
dass die entscheidungsträger uns alle
unterstützen die dritte welle zu brechen
mit verordnungen von wirksame strategien
und auch mit konsequenter umsetzung
dieser strategie erst nach brechen der
dritten welt können kontrollierte
öffnung geschehen und dann unter
berücksichtigung relevant
größten also der sieben tage incidents
dem anteil der kogit fälle in den
intensiv medizinisch betreuten patienten
der wöchentlichen inzidenz
hospitalisierte mit menschen über 60 und
dem anteil der kontrakt personen die
durch die gesundheitsämter noch
nachvollzogen werden können dann
kontrollieren wir mit 19 und da muss man
hin und zwar so schnell wie möglich wir
müssen die zahlen unterbunden es ist
naiv zu glauben bei hohen zahlen das
virus weg testen zu können
das gelingt nicht und das sehen sie auch
aktuell in verschiedenen regionen
unseres landes das funktioniert nicht
herzlichen dank professor bieler
professor weber kaarst ja ich möchte
mich zunächst erstmal den stacks der
vorredner uneingeschränkt anschließen
wir brauchen jetzt an dieser stelle
eine kontrolle der infektions dynamik
sonst werden wir das in auch in zukunft
auf den intensivstationen nicht mehr
adäquat leisten können wir haben seit
anfang märz jetzt für den letzten monat
2000 patienten mehr die wir auf den
intensivstationen behandeln müssen
ich will ihnen das mal die zahlen sind
alle genannt ich will gar nicht weitere
zahlen sagen ich will ja einfach mal so
ein bisschen erzählen wie das sozusagen
bei uns im klinischen alltag aussieht
machen sie sich mal stellen sich mal vor
der intensivstation 12 bis 14 betten
jeder dieser patienten ist an krebs
erkrankt und ein großteil dieser
patienten brauchen extra corporate
verfahren
das ist im moment mein klinischer alltag
und bauchlage ist ein ganz klares
erwiesen ist wie eine wichtige maßnahme
die wir therapie als therapeutische
strategie haben wenn sie das machen dann
brauchen sie vier bis fünf personen die
einen patienten auf den bauch legen sie
brauchen pro lagerung etwa eine halbe
stunde werden sie 14 patienten haben
dann machen sie das sieben stunden am
tag in eine richtung
das heißt sie müssen das extrem durch
strukturieren und sie haben dann
sozusagen 12 bis 16 stunden zeit um das
gleiche dann wieder rückwärts zu machen
das passiert im moment tag von tag zu
tag das ist eine immense belastung was
die intensivstation in ganz deutschland
schultern und ist allein durch die
zahlen auch nicht ausgedrückt für berlin
kann ich das sehr gut sagen was ich kann
seit einem jahr machen wir haben seit
einem jahr eine unten die uhr tag und
nacht eine zentrale koordinierungsstelle
die jeden einzelnen
intensivmedizinischen kranken patienten
auf die einzelnen intensiv auf die
einzelne intensivstation zuweist damit
wir von vorneherein eine sachgerechte
medizinisch sachgerechte belegung der
der krankenhäuser generieren können und
wir haben gleichzeitig ein sehr
ausgedehntes telemedizinisches netzwerke
aufgebaut das kommt aus dem
forschungsprojekt was es vorher gegeben
hat und jetzt sozusagen auch in
verbindung mit dem rkw auch
weitergeführt wird die kollegen dort die
dieses projekt betreuen sind auch tag
und nacht mit diesen 38 notfall clinton
die wir in berlin haben vernetzt und
machen telemedizinische visiten zum teil
100 am tag mit mehreren personen und
dann am ende auch klar und deutlich zu
sehen welcher patient muss aus welcher
klinik zu welchem zeitpunkt
gegebenenfalls in die nächst höhere
stufe gelegt werden das ist etwas was
das einfach seit einem jahr jeden tag
passiert das ganze gelingt auch nur weil
wir das in einer extrem enge
zusammenarbeit mit der berliner
feuerwehr machen
die sind nämlich diejenigen die die
patienten von a nach b transportieren
und wir hatten in der höchst phase der
auslastung jetzt jahreswende waren mehr
als 50 prozent der feuerwehreinsätze die
sie hierdurch berlin gesehen haben waren
sekundär verlegung für kugel prozenten
das ist im moment in die situation die
wir haben
er gibt es schon angesprochen wir
brauchen oder wir müssen dahin kommen
dass wir
regional weniger belastete regionen dass
wir uns dort hin um verteilen und
patienten dorthin abfälligen das ist
etwas was bereits passiert ich habe
gestern mit dem medizinischen
koordinator aus thüringen gesprochen
heute ist bezwang gestern ist die
anfrage zur strategisch patienten
kollegen aus thüringen in andere
bundesländer über das kleeblatt system
gestartet worden da beginnen die ersten
strategischen prozent fliegen in andere
bereiche damit wir überhaupt in der lage
sind diese diesen strom der patienten zu
bewältigen und wir laufen im moment
sehen den august in spitzen belasten die
wir sozusagen um die jahreswende hatten
oder auch noch weiter dass man auch
sagen muss und auch das ist schon
angesprochen worden
das ganze klingt jetzt schon nur weil
wir in den krankenhäusern hier in berlin
nur noch elektrisch programm machen
sondern nur noch notfallprogramm machen
uns sehr die eigentliche operation sind
mit zehn trinken operation versorgen
können
auch das bedeutet auch für die nicht
kurven patienten eine erhebliche
einschränkung die in ihrer versorgung
machen sie sich mal eines klar es wird
immer gesagt es gibt doch tausende von
freien intensivbetten wenn sie auf steve
register gehen und die länder karte
angucken dann sehen sie dass in den
meisten regionen wir nur noch 10 prozent
frei intensivbetten kapazitäten haben
was bedeuten zehn prozent die
durchschnittliche größe der
intensivstation des zehn bis zwölf
betten das bedeutet pro intensivstation
genau ein wert dieses geld haben sie für
den schlaganfall für den herzinfarkt
patienten für den unfall patienten für
den büros operieren prozent und für den
co-präsidenten das ist die situation wie
sie im moment ist und das heißt wer ist
es auch wenn angeklungen ich glaube das
ist auch wirklich wichtig zu sagen
bislang ist es uns gelungen praktisch
die komplette überlastung und einen
sozusagen ich sage jetzt mal platt
absaufen der der in das kurze zeit zu
sehen der intensivstation zu vermeiden
das haben wir in deutschland geschafft
das ist ein wirklich herausragendes
merkmal das will ich an dieser stelle
auch sagen alle zusammen
geschafft und an dieser stelle ist es
wirklich extrem wichtig dass wir das im
moment nicht verspielen und das geht aus
meiner sicht tatsächlich nur durch eben
jetzt wirklich effektive maßnahmen die
die infektions dynamik könnten
gleichzeitig auch das ist gesagt worden
das ganze wird selbstverständlich nur
wenn wir mit aller kraft die wir haben
jetzt auch die impfstrategie
weiterverfolgung ausbauen
vielen dank herzlichen dank bekommen wir
zu fragen ich habe bereits jetzt schon
wieder eine liste von 15 fragestellern
insofern bitte die beschränkung auf eine
frage eine nachfrage
wir beginnen mit frau spiekermann sie
haben alle betont wie wichtig kontakt
beschränkungen weiter beschränken sind
es wird er politisch diskutiert über die
ausgangssperre es gibt da erheblichen
widerstand also aus den ländern
aus den fraktionen aber auch also dass
man schon heute juristen wie bewerten
sie diese kritik bestehens weise diesen
lieder stadt angesichts der situation
dazu erst einmal auch zur einordnung es
geht ja nicht darum ob jemand alleine
abends um zehn unterwegs ist das kein
infektionsrisiko dann die frage ist um
die es geht von wo nach wo sind wir
unterwegs haben und nicht selten ist es
von treffen
das ist ja normal die lebensrealität das
ist bei mir im münsterland auf dem dorf
so das ist hier in der stadt so und was
wir hier sehen übrigens auch in den
ausbruchsgeschehen ist dass es vor allem
die privaten zusammenhänge sind in denen
es vermehrt auch nicht zuletzt durch b11
sie mit auch einer höheren
ansteckungsfähigkeit zu infektionen
kommt dann denkt man sich auch den
nachbarn oder oder den schwager den
kenne ich gut da passiert schon nichts
oder den freund aber es kann eben doch
was passieren weil derjenige
möglicherweise infektiöses ohne es zu
wissen weil er keine symptome hat oder
sie und deswegen sind die ausgangs
beschränkungen ein mittel und es gibt
durchaus auch studien aus anderen
ländern
dass es ein wirksames mittel ist um
kontakte einzuschränken
die ansonsten privat stattfinden darum
geht's das ist auch keine dauerlösung
das sagte jetzt keiner ich es gibt
übrigens länder in europa die haben das
über monate
die studien zeigen allerdings ist
besonders wirksam als eine lösung wie
wir sie jetzt brauchen um einen klaren
schnitt zu machen
zwei drei wochen das ist ja das was wir
hier eigentlich seit wochen sagen
miteinander zwei drei wochen dieses land
und ostern wäre aus meiner sicht
eigentlich eine gute gelegenheit gewesen
wie letztes jahr ostern so runter zu
fahren dass wir die wellen brechen und
dann anschließend schritte gehen zu
können
test gestützt und dazu gehören als nicht
dauer maßnahme aber als notwendige als
auch harte ich will das gar nicht weg
reden das ist in einer freiheitlichen
gesellschaft eine sehr einschneidende
maßnahme aber als eine notwendige
vorübergehende maßnahme zur stärkeren
kontakt beschränkung gerade im privaten
bereich darum geht es aus meiner sicht
ist das angesichts des
infektionsgeschehen es tatsächlich eine
notwendige option zu sagen insofern
sinnvoll weil man dann fangen die leute
diszipliniert dass sie zu hause ich dann
nicht treffen da er soll forscher sagen
ja dass die ansteckung möglichkeit
draußen bei also das ist drin passiert
und dass sie dabei 99 prozent habe ich
gestern gehört liegt kann ich verstehen
also das was ohne
disziplinierungsmaßnahme geht oder es
hat sich jetzt negativ an also dass um
die maßnahme geht um die leute ist es
sein dass sich an kontakten schlecht und
ergreifend und kontakte und begegnungen
einzuschränken
das ist ja weiterhin das was uns am
schwersten fällt heben von uns wir
menschen wollen anderen menschen
begegnen und seit zwölf monaten war 13
mittlerweile ist das schwerste das dass
in dieser pandemie halt besser nicht so
passiert wie sonst und da ist das
abendliche sich treffen in aller regel
ja ein privates und dort kommt es eben
verstärkt marc mutmaßlich auch mit der
mutation zu tun zu entsprechenden
infektionen gerade natürlich in
geschlossenen räumen der nächste schritt
wäre ja wissen sie ich versuche es immer
eine perspektive zu wissen jetzt die
wellen brechen die zahlen runter bringen
dann kann man
nächsten schritt gehen gerade auch mit
blick auf die jahreszeit in dem wir
hinein gehen im außenbereich deutlich
mehr test gestützt zu öffnen
außengastronomie veranstaltungen draußen
meinetwegen auch das fußballspiel mit
hygiene konzept und tests aber in der
jetzigen phase in der sie sind müssen
wir erst diese welle brechen und dann
auch mit mehr begegnungen draußen die
perspektive geben zu können
die reihenfolge ist wichtig nach der
aussprache hatte auch der kollege zenker
gefragt das ist glaube ich jetzt
beantwortet aber dazu noch kollege poker
von hdr sparen es gibt rechtliche
bedenken gegen die ausgangssperre was
macht sie sicher dass die ausgangssperre
wie sie im infektionsschutzgesetz steht
vor gericht standhält
und es ist so und auch das gehört in
einem rechtsstaat dazu dass es ja soweit
ich das die letzten 13 14 monate
überblicke gegen jede maßnahmen auch
bedenken gegeben hat und rechtliche zum
teil auch maßnahmen mehr gegeben hat
gerichtsverfahren und urteile gegeben
hat dass wir jetzt es ist ja schon
angekündigt ohne zweifel auch in diesem
fall geben es kommt ja entscheidend auf
die begründung an den begründung
zusammenhang habe ich gerade dargestellt
und eine bundesgesetzliche regelung ist
eine die dann tatsächlich auch vor dem
verfassungsgericht möglicherweise
überprüft werden wird wir jedenfalls
seitens der bundesregierung und auch mit
den beiden verfassungsressorts dem
justizministerium und dem
innenministerium die an der prüfung der
verhältnismäßigkeit und allen
verfassungsrechtlichen fragen intensiv
beteiligt sind gehen davon aus dass das
in der aktuellen lage angesichts der
notwendigkeit als vorübergehende
maßnahme trägt die nächste frage an
herrn minister sparen ich habe eine
frage zu den impfstoff lieferungen
sie haben gestern neue zahlen
veröffentlicht und daran sieht man
kommentarlos das in dieser woche zum
beispiel mehr als 500.000 impfdosen von
astrazeneca nicht geliefert werden die
angekündigt worden und in der letzten
aprilwoche nochmal 15 millionen weniger
astrazeneca dosen geliefert dann als
insgesamt zwei millionen dosen weniger
april ist es zutreffend
und haben sie andererseits erkenntnis
darüber dass dieser impfstoff weniger
nachgefragt wird und liegen bleibt
zurzeit also zuerst einmal die
veröffentlichten zahlen die sie meinen
tippe ich jedenfalls die lieferung sind
die lieferungen und die liefer wochen an
die länder und die arztpraxis gehabt wir
haben einen hersteller der liefert
konsequent immer am selben wochen
zeitraum nämlich anfang der woche das
ist bei ortec und sehr verlässlich die
anderen hersteller liefern nicht selten
mitte oder ende der woche und meistens
auch mit kürzerer kündigungsfrist und
wenn wir dann zum beispiel als 13 meter
in die arztpraxen bringen wollen und wir
ja die anlieferung in aller regel anfang
der woche machen ist es so dass die
lieferung die wir rechnen könnten als
eine lieferung in dieser kalenderwoche
die aber erst am samstag kommt erst
nächste woche
logischerweise anfang der woche an die
arztpraxen ausliefern und deswegen das
so zu sagen welchen sich jetzt versetzt
das ende dieser woche kommt die 500.000
ich weiß nicht genau die größen und
damit das was sie angesprochen haben
wird nächste woche an die arztpraxen
ausgeliefert und deswegen stellen wir da
in unseren listen banes ankommt im
impfzentrum oder in den arztpraxen und
nicht mehr wann ist bei uns ankommt ich
glaube das ist der entscheidende
zeitpunkt wann ist es vor ort verfügbar
um verimpft zu werden und dadurch ist
sozusagen in dem überlappen vom
wochenende in die nächste woche
möglicherweise dieser eindruck
entstanden den sie gerade angesprochen
haben das gilt auch für die 1,7
millionen dosen am ende der übernächsten
woche die dann in die übernächste woche
in die arztpraxen geben was die frage
astra zenica angeht sehen wir an dem was
auch die arztpraxen bestellt haben
übrigens letzte woche 35.000 arztpraxen
die sich beteiligt haben diese woche
45.000 arztpraxen die bedarf angemeldet
haben
für nächste woche haben schon 50.000
arztpraxen bedarf angemeldet das heißt
also die zahl der mit impfenden ärzte
steigt und es ist relativ ausgewogen
astra zenica und bayon tag bestellt
worden wir haben im moment aber auch
gesagt was dazu zu sagen dass jede
arztpraxis auch von beiden herstellern
dosen bekommt und noch gibt es auch sehr
viele über 60-jährige patientinnen und
patienten in den arztpraxen die ohne
zweifel und gut wirksam nach empfehlung
geimpft werden können und auch viele
unter 60 jährige die nach individueller
risikoaufklärung bereit sind sich impfen
zu lassen
wir haben gäste mit gestern mit der
erste schafft und der kassenärztlichen
bundesvereinigung und der ständigen
impfkommission vereinbart dass wir den
ärzten sozusagen auch noch mal eine
information senden zu der frage impfen
mit astrazeneca eine weitere
informationen gab schon welche aber
nochmal eine weitere um sicherheit zu
geben bei unter 60 jährigen aber mein
eindruck ist also welche nordrhein
westfalen oder berlin nehme die
ankündigung alle über 60 jährigen können
sich mit astra zenica impfen hat dazu
geführt dass die hotlines überfüllt
waren
insofern scheint es mir weiterhin eine
bereitschaft zu geben sich auch mit
diesem impfstoff impfen zu lassen was
richtig und wichtig ist er ist gut und
wirksam zu den infizierten der
epidemiologe gérard krause hat jetzt
wieder bei tagesschau.de kritisiert dass
man so wenig weiß über die personen die
sich tatsächlich infizieren im moment
und ein element oder ein mittel das zu
beheben wäre ja zum beispiel dass die
infizierten ihre berufe zum beispiel war
angeben müssten dann müsste man zum
beispiel ein bisschen mehr gibt es pläne
das zu verändern dass dem robert koch
institut das ja dieses wissen nicht hat
zum beispiel die berufe der infizierten
mitgeteilt glauben müssen also eine
entsprechende änderung gegen ihn nur
gesetzlich es wird dann auch eine
datenschutzrechtliche abwägung einmal
mehr seien jetzt sagen ja fehler in der
pandemie ist datenschutz nicht so
wichtig da gibt es unterschiedliche
einschätzungen zu jedenfalls auch beim
bundesdatenschutzbeauftragten und im
justizministerium
und es ist am ende natürlich ein
zusätzlicher aufwand
wissen sie das erlebte in den arztpraxen
auch gerade
einerseits gibt es kritik dafür dass wir
nicht mehr sagen können in welcher
welches alter genau der geimpfte hat und
die gleichzeitig auf der anderen seite
gibt es die kritik dass so viel
bürokratie in den arztpraxen ist wenn
wir informationen haben
erhöht gleichzeitig den aufwand im
alltag bei dem was so eingegeben und
festgehalten werden muss und das ist
genau die balance und das gleichgewicht
dass wir da finden müssen und das ist
neben den datenschutzrechtlichen fragen
auch ne frage natürlich das des
aufwandes wie sie welche daten erheben
und dann auch verarbeiten ich habe zwei
fragen die beschäftigen sich mit
jüngeren kindern und jugendlichen was
sie wegen davon der dpa fragen an herrn
professor wie la vie beschreiben und
bewerten sie das infektionsgeschehen bei
den unter 15-jährigen und was ist von
dort für das allgemeine
infektionsgeschehen zu erwarten wie
sicher ist in diesem zusammenhang in den
schulen ab einer inzidenz von 100 mit 2
test pro woche wechsel unterricht zu
machen oder dazu passt die frage von
kollegen buchsteiner the pioneer auch an
professor wähler welche rolle spielen
die schulen als treiber der pandemie und
sind es nicht die ungeimpften eltern die
derzeit das höchste ansteckungsrisiko
haben und zwar nicht ihre eigenen kinder
also zunächst nochmal prinzipiell etwas
gesagt je höher die inzidenz steigt
desto höher ist das risiko dass man sich
ansteckt das gilt für jeden egal wie alt
oder jung er ist und je höher die
inzidenz steigt desto höher ist also
auch die chance dass sich kinder
anstecken
das ist ja auch klar und kinder können
sich genauso leicht mit dem virus
anstecken wie erwachsene nur zum glück
wenn sie nicht in demselben maße als in
der häufigkeit krank aber kinder können
natürlich auch und tun dies auch andere
menschen anstecken ich möchte nochmal
prinzipiell sagen diese begrifflichkeit
treiber der infektion führt immer wieder
dazu dass man das große ganze aus dem
blick lässt das große ganze ist dass man
sich in innenräumen hauptsächlich an
steckt das ist das risiko ist deutlich
größer als außen ist ja auch klar wenn
ich infiziert wäre ich bin aus
symptomatisch fühle mich gesund
spreche redet dann fliegt das virus aus
meinem aus meiner lunge heraus und dann
stecke ich natürlich draußen deutlich
welten an alles drin und das heißt ganz
klar schulen sind natürlich orte
infektion stattfinden weil dort ja
mehrere menschen zusammen in einem raum
sind und darum haben wir schon vor
monaten und viele andere kolleginnen und
kollegen vor monaten konzepte entworfen
wie man sich davor schützt so das heißt
also wenn wir jetzt die instanzen wenn
die weiter steigen und die inzidenz
nicht runtergebracht werden dann werden
natürlich auch die anzahl der
infektionen in den schulen steigen
und ob nun die eltern die kinder
angesteckt haben oder die kinder die
eltern ist dann letztlich auch nicht
mehr entscheidend sondern es ist
entscheidend dass überhaupt infektionen
weitergegeben werden
und wenn etwa ab einer instanz von 200
erst maßnahmen getroffen werden dann
wird natürlich folgendes geschehen dann
werden so viele kinder positiv sein dass
die schulen angeschlossen werden man
erkennt die kinder ja früher dass sie
infiziert sind
man testet das virus ja nicht weg man
erkennt dass eine infektion in der
schulklasse ist und die chance dass die
infektionen da ist es im größeren die
inzidenz größer ist das heißt also mit
testen erkennen sie früher eine
infektion und wenn die inzidenz bei 100
ist dann wenn sie halb so oft einen
positiven fall haben wir wenn die
inzidenz bei 200 ist sie werden also
einfach nur die schulen deshalb
schließen weil sie immer positiv
getestet werden das ist doch klar
also das gilt für jeden lebensbereich
ich möchte das wirklich noch mal betonen
wir stecken uns hauptsächlich drinnen an
und je mehr menschen und die engel sie
und je länger sie zusammen sind desto
größer ist die wahrscheinlichkeit dass
einer den anderen an steckt da gibt es
auch nichts darüber zu diskutieren oder
in frage zu stellen das ist fakt und je
größer die inzidenz ist desto größer ist
die chance dass der ansteckung
stattfindet wo es war die inzidenz
runter bringen dann können wir testen
wenn wir nur positive testen dann werden
die schulen geschlossen wird so wird
positiv getestet werden ich würde es gar
nicht erst zulassen dass so viele gehen
sie denn zu hoch gehen die nächste frage
kollege bastian hat eine frage auch mit
blick auf die perspektive für den sommer
herr lauterbach der jetzt nicht als
jemand bekannt ist geschehen kleinredet
hat gesagt er glaube nach wie vor daran
das ist ein guter sommer werden kann
glauben sie angesichts der dramatik der
funktionstrakt visier beschrieben haben
auch daran das ist ein guter sommer wird
also ist ja alles keine glaubensfrage
sondern eine frage von einschätzung und
die frage also aus heutiger sicht und
mit dem erfolgen die wir beim individual
schutz beim impfen sehen es ist jetzt
wichtig im moment sehen wir
individuellen schutz bei den geimpften
sie infizieren sich deutlich oder einer
gruppe von gästen indes gibt es deutlich
weniger infektionen sehen wir die
pflegeeinrichtungen deutlich weniger
ausbrüche und vor allem sie werden nicht
krank und wir vermeiden krankheit und
tod ist wir gruppen immunität erreicht
haben wird es eben bis in den sommer und
zwar nicht anfang juli sondern im sommer
im dritten quartal dauern und gleichwohl
hat es damit natürlich verbunden
die chance das ist ein deutlich besserer
sommer wird als der winter war er klar
wird dass also die frage ist immer wie
definiert was war das guter sommer wie
definiert man guter sommer ob dann
gleich schon wieder alle bis zu den
seychellen fliegen müssen weiß ich nicht
bis zur nordsee wird man sicher kommen
die frage ist jetzt erst mal wie gut
gelingt ist uns jetzt diese welle zu
brechen und gleichzeitig mit dem impfen
den entscheidenden unterschied zu machen
und dann kann dieser sommer und wird
dieser sommer ein anderer werden könne
als letzter sommer
ob das schon zu beginn des sommers so
ist weil gestern mich jemand sagt er die
grenze ich habe aber jetzt anfang juli
gebucht wenn du im sommer sagt gilt das
auch schon im juli sind wir sollten
jetzt miteinander die dinge entsprechend
einordnen und wir sehen ja gerade an
dieser mutation bei 117 das immer mal
wieder auch etwas passieren und kommen
kann und gleichzeitig bin ich sehr
zuversichtlich dass wir im sommer mit
dem was die impfkampagne
jetzt auch hergibt in der weiteren
entwicklung eine deutlich andere lager
unbedingt umsatz sind sie da
optimistisch oder pessimistisch
angesichts der entwicklungen bei dem
jeder kollege angesprochen die probleme
sind da sich die zusätzliche lieferung
sonntag hat sich da ihre prognose
verändert oder ihre unser hauptlieferant
wenn ich es so nennen darf oder volumen
lieferant ist japan tag übrigens erweist
es sich als wirklicher segen dass wir
uns schon seit herbst letzten jahres um
das werk in marburg mit dem unternehmen
gekümmert haben und die zulassung weil
das jetzt einen echten unterschied macht
von den 70 millionen dosen die wir
mittlerweile sind sehr 80 millionen
dosen nach der entscheidung oder der der
der information gestern das 50 millionen
dosen für die eu vorgezogen werden ins
zweite quartal das sind für deutschland
etwa neun millionen dosen an sind von 80
millionen dosen knapp 50 millionen von
biontech im zweiten quartal
das gibt schon mal viel trittsicherheit
auch mit diesem impfstoff in der
verlässlichen liefersituation aber auch
die anderen impfstoffe sind ja gut und
wirksam und mit entsprechenden
empfehlungen ja auch im täglichen
einsatz bei uns und deswegen jahr wird
dieser zweitens zweite quartal ein
entscheidender unterschied machen und
auch machen können sie mal sehen wir
haben das erste quartal etwa zehn
prozent der deutschen geimpft
wir werden jetzt in einem monat im april
weitere zehn prozent schon schaffen wenn
er bis ende des monats plus - vielleicht
jetzt einfach aber 20 prozent erreichen
ja heute schon 17,6 also das heißt habe
die geschwindigkeit zunimmt und sie wird
weiter zunehmen und zu nehmen können
es ist passiert exakt so im übrigen wie
im dezember vorhergesagt sabine visa
fragt professor weber carstens triage
erörterung sind regelmäßig zur seite
geschoben worden in dieser situation
diese situation komme man schon nicht
wird jetzt eine triage nötig und nach
welchen maßstäben geht man dann auf den
intensivstationen vor
nein ich denke also wir haben keine
träne situation und wir hatten bislang
auch keine reale situation und ich
glaube wenn die genannten maßnahmen
kommt der kränkung plus impfung wenn wir
das wirklich gut umsetzen dann werden
wir auch nicht da in eine tragische
situation dann laufen wir haben
natürlich das hatte ich vorher schon
gedacht wir brauchen jetzt so ein
instrument wie strategische patienten
verlegung damit wir in den verschiedenen
bereichen überhaupt den platz schaffen
können und wir werden auch gerade ist
das vorhin angesprochen worden
extrakorporale um membran
optimierungslösungen unterstützung auch
da werden wir zentren übergreifend auch
bundesland übergreifen patienten
verlegung machen müssen um zu
gewährleisten dass die patienten einer
solchen therapie zugeführt werden können
das ist klar dass das auf uns zukommt
eine tragische situation haben bin ich
und ich glaube auch nicht dass wir daran
haben ja sagen da völlig die debatte
letzten tages ist ja normal unterschied
wenn man jetzt erstmal eine priorität
setzt oder in der trias situation dass
und ob ich jetzt eine nicht notwendige
unbedingt notwendige operation
verschiebe ist das für den patienten der
diese operation für sich erwartet hat
schwer die verschobene hüftoperation die
verschobene knieoperationen verschobene
rückenoperation sie ist vielleicht nicht
medizinisch jetzt akut lebensnotwendig
aber es ist für den patienten natürlich
hart die aussage wir müssen jetzt eine
geplante operation wir wissen noch nicht
genau wie weit verschieben
aber es ist keine triage aber diese
entscheidung dass patienten nicht etwa
ihre operation jetzt immer bekommen
können die nicht dringend medizinisch
notwendig ist die situation haben wir
aber ich finde wir müssen die begriffe
da richtig zuordnen das ist was anderes
als das was eigentlich mittrage gemeint
nächste frage herr kollege yüksel rtl
und endlich für eine frage an herrn
minister sparen es gibt da gibt es ja
immer wieder rückschläge
in dieser woche jetzt johnson johnson
die lieferung verzögert sich es gibt ja
das versprechen das zum spätsommer jede
ein angebot gemacht werden kann man
dieses versprechen überhaupt nach
angesichts der zahlen die ich ihnen
gerade genannt habe stand heute ja weil
sie ja es gibt teilweise rückschläge
aber die positiven nachrichten kann man
ja vielleicht auch mal genauso immer
dann wenn ich habe es gerade gesagt dass
etwa als europäische union im zweiten
quartal 50 millionen impfdosen biontech
mehr bekommen das sind 9 millionen gut
neun millionen mehr für deutschland im
zweiten quartal
das macht natürlich einen entscheidenden
unterschied dafür neun millionen
menschen mehr oder weniger eine erste
impfung geben können erst im zweiten
quartal auch für unsere impfkampagne und
mit den impfstoffen die wir haben
piontek moderner astrazeneca und johnson
& johnson & johnson johnson ist jetzt in
der überprüfung das scheint ja vor allem
auch eine frage annahme jetzt des vector
impfstoffes zu sein dass es dort in
bestimmten seltenen zusammenhängen aber
eben ein bestimmtes risiko bei
thrombosen geben kann heißt ja nicht
dass dieser impfstoff nicht einsetzbar
ist sondern er wird dann eben mit den
entsprechenden empfehlungen eingesetzt
und damit bin ich weiterhin stand heute
mit allem was wir haben und erwarten
dürfen
sehr sehr sicher dass wir im sommer
werden alle impfen können wenn jetzt das
werk in marburg abbrennt ja ich will
noch mal sagen ich kann ihnen das halt
nur mit dem stand heute sagen und dem
wissensstand heute und allem was wir
heute ein preisen können werden wir das
im sommer schafft charlotte kurz von der
pharmazeutischen zeitung fragt herr
lauterbach fordert angesichts der
aktuellen situation einen nationalen
notfall zulassung für die kur weg
impfstoff wie bewerten sie die
möglichkeit einer solchen notfall
zulassung einen notfall zu lassen ist ja
eine maßnahme die letztlich von von
anderen institutionen getroffen werden
muss ich gerade
wenn wir über die diskussion gerade
nachdenken unser land hat doch in den
letzten monaten mit den maßnahmen der
zulassung mit der genauen betrachtung
auch von eventuellen unerwünschten
nebenwirkungen den richtigen weg gewählt
und ich denke dass wir immer sicher
gehen sollten und insofern und unter dem
aspekt wie viel impfstoffe wir zu
erwarten haben wehre ich mich entscheide
das nicht aber ich kann auch dazu
eigentlich nicht sagen aber ich sehe
nicht die notwendigkeit einer note
zulassung für pure weg momentan wir
haben bisher immer den weg gewählt dass
wir erst mal abwarten wie die klinischen
studien verlaufen und ich sehe keinen
grund diesen weg zu verlassen
aber wie gesagt das ist eine frage die
die zulassungs institutionen beantworten
wenn ich als jemand der es entscheidet
vielleicht noch etwas dazu sagen die
frage ja weg ich denke im moment nicht
daran dass nicht schnell genug die
zulassungsbehörde ist sondern an den
daten
wir haben noch nicht die
wirksamkeitsdaten zum beispiel und ohne
wirksamkeitsdaten ist auf einen notfall
zulassung nicht möglich und deswegen
finde ich sehr wichtig in der
öffentlichen debatte das jetzt nicht der
eindruck entsteht die könnten für werk
einfach zu lassen und unterschied machen
sie tun es aber mal wieder nicht weil
sie irgendwie prinzipienreiter sind die
daten sind noch gar nicht da in dem
moment wo die daten da sind auch was
wirksamkeit angeht wird die
zulassungsbehörde das sehr schnell
machen und dann eben zu einer
entsprechenden zulassung wie bisher auch
kommen aber auch für einen notfall
zulassung brauchen sie wirksam kreistag
die liste von kalinka ich würde ganz
gern noch mal auf den anfang zurück
kommen nämlich die maßnahmen die man
machen kann damit die infektion nicht
steigen
jetzt haben sie gesagt die
ministerpräsidenten können ja jetzt
schon handeln müssen nicht auf die
notbremse warten vielleicht könnt ihr
mal die 23 aus ihrer sicht
entscheidenden maßnahmen denen die denn
die ministerpräsident jetzt schon
umsetzen sollten die frage wer das eine
sind die privaten kontakt beschränkungen
ich meine wir haben ja ein beispiel zum
beispiel weil ich gestern
zufällig gegen den anderen thema aber
wir sprachen darüber mit dem
ministerpräsident von schleswig-holstein
schwach flensburg ist ja ein beispiel
dafür
aber es gibt viele andere beispiele in
deutschland auch da wo eine erhöhte
inzidenz entstanden ist in diesem fall
noch verbunden mit einer mutation damals
wo damit sehr konsequentem handeln dass
kein leicht gefallen ist und am
wenigsten den bürgerinnen und bürgern
ist aber gelungen ist das sehr zügig
auch entsprechend wieder wieder zu
brechen und wir sehen gerade im moment
dass das thema der privaten kontakte ein
thema ist da geht es um ausgangs
beschränke und da geht es um die frage
von kontakt beschränkungen wir haben
gerade die frage der schulen besprochen
und auch das fällt ja schwer
sie müssen nicht auf immer zu denjenigen
gehört die gesagt haben schulen mit als
letztes schließen aber mit den
veränderungen die wir sehen im
infektionsgeschehen und im übrigen
gerade in der verlängerung nach ostern
werde es natürlich in regionen mit
dynamischen infektionsgeschehen eine
eine entsprechende eine mögliche option
um nur zwei zu nennen der
instrumentenkasten ist ja da es ist in
teilen im übrigen auch schon angelegt
alles in den beschlüssen der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz ist in
einigen bundesländern ja auch umgesetzt
aber ich habe im moment so den eindruck
viele warten irgendwie auf dieses gesetz
das im übrigen nur die notbremse
wiedergibt notbremse heißt eigentlich
das ist die bremse die man nimmt wenn
die anderen bremsen nicht funktioniert
haben und das agieren auch vor 100 und
101 ident ist dann eben auch genauso
wichtig und deswegen gibt es mir vor
allem darum bitte nicht alle jetzt auf
dieses gesetz warten
das alleine und das auch erst ende
nächster woche in kraft treten
löst unser aktuelles problem nicht das
was gerade er lieber karstens mit ruhm
hat auch in den stationen jeder tag
früher ist ein tag besser damit
durchbrachen gerade zu den schulen
das war eine entspannung und am bieler
ist es dann nicht unverantwortlich wenn
die inzidenz grenze bei 200 ansetzt und
nicht bei 100
also aus meiner sicht ist die 200er
inzidenz grenze zu hoch weil man dann
sehr viele infektionen haben wird und
man wird durch die testungen die
infektion früher feststellen und dann
wird das ergebnis sein dass man aufgrund
von testungen kinder aus der schule
nehmen muss oder ganze klasse neben
wieder aus der schule nehmen muss dass
die faktische entscheidung die über die
testungen dann stattfinden wird
das sehe ich auch so was wir jetzt
erleben ist also was wir hier sehen ist
ist nicht per se leichter weil die
gleichen themen natürlich eine rolle
spielen einen konsens zu finden im
deutschen bundestag als in der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz erwartbarer
weise wie es auch in der wenn wir hier
miteinander diskutieren würden würden
wir wahrscheinlich auch eine zeit
brauchen bis sie uns auf die maßnahmen
geeinigt hätten
weil natürlich sehr unterschiedliche
aspekte eine rolle spielen gerade auch
bei schulen und kitas wir können aus
epidemiologischer sicht und als
bundesminister für gesundheit und herr
professor wieder gerade auch aus seiner
sicht als lka präsident also ich kann
nur sagen
gerade bei den schulen gerade mit den
erfahrungen die wir mit der mutation
haben kann ich mir auch deutlich früher
als bei 200 diese maßnahmen vorstellen
unbedingt aber eben auch was die
abiturjahrgänge betrifft also die kommen
jetzt alle zusammen und schreiben ihr
abitur und wir haben jetzt auch gerade
von ihm gehört der professor
das ist uns sagen die haupt ansteckung
sword und am ansteckung swords und
luftfilter jetzt sind ja im traum als
der realität also was kann man denn da
tun also hat ja gesagt dass er alles
gequatsche aber sehen sie das ein
bisschen anders
also was kann man tun meint es gibt
genug leere räume wo man menschen
einsetzen kann in großem abstand wir
sitzen da hier unter anderem auch
zusammen und tragen alle masken und es
gibt hier in konzept und das kann man in
schulen doch genauso tun
man kann abiturarbeiten sogar in
turnhallen schreiben also ganz ehrlich
es gibt doch genügend möglichkeiten in
diesem land räume zu finden in denen man
für eine gewisse zeit eine bestimmte
tätigkeit absolviert ja ich weiß nicht
wo das problem liegt leider mit blick
auf dessen abschlussklassen ja auch
immer aus willich adressiert das ist
jetzt für den jeweiligen schüler
jeweilige schülerin für den lebensweg
einfach eine ganz wichtige frage und das
wie eine abwägungsfrage und dann kommt
es auf die konzepte an und wenn die
schulen leer sind kann man theoretisch
in ihren klassen also mit entsprechenden
abstand und maßnahmen ist das aus meiner
sicht machbar weil das wie eine
abwägungsfrage ist für die schülerinnen
und schüler natürlich eine enorm
wichtige frage ist auch für ihre ganze
biografie ob jetzt die möglichkeit
besteht den abschluss zu machen oder
nicht
aber daneben unter den bedingungen die
herr professor lieder geschrieben
malte kreutzfeldt fragt von der taz war
kürzlich bekannt geworden dass
schnelltests zu beginn einer infektion
drei tage lang negativ ausfallen obwohl
der gegen der getestete bereits
infektiös ist was bedeutet das für den
plan öffnung an diese tests zu koppeln
zuerst einmal ist das jetzt keine neue
erkenntnis dass die schnelltests deren
sozusagen der richtig gute aussagekraft
haben eben in einem bestimmten moment
der entwicklung sozusagen nämlich dann
wenn man selbst besonders infektiös auch
ist über die qualitäten aber auch das
was schnelltests nicht können haben wir
ja hier schon auch schon vielfach
informiert und deswegen ist es so
wichtig ein negatives testergebnis nicht
als freifahrtschein zu nehmen es ist ein
indikator mittlerweile auch ein
vergleichsweise guter indikator für die
frage ob man akut sehr infektiös ist
nicht ob man per sie infiziert ist aber
es ist auch ein indikator der ist nicht
für drei tage trägt an der an der stelle
also ich mache mittlerweile zwei bis
vier mal die woche mindestens einen
entsprechenden schnelltest weil einfach
die aussagekraft eine sehr sehr
vorübergehende ist ja und wie
das ist wir haben eine kurve und dann
steigt die viruslast an und da gibt es
bestimmte durchschnittswerte die
variieren natürlich bei den einzelnen
personen aber es ist klar wir sagen
deshalb dass so ein test eine gültigkeit
in anführungszeichen von etwa 24 stunden
hat genau aus dem grund also das ist von
vornherein so kommuniziert worden und
das ist auch wichtig dass man das ich
freue mich auch dass das minister spa
noch mal betont es ist kein frei testen
möglich und ich sage das auch immer
wieder schauen sie doch jetzt nach
tübingen oder schauen sie auch ins
saarland mit testen alleine kann man
doch das virus nicht runter bringen das
ist doch klar bei einer gewissen
inzidenz bei der niedrige incident kann
man schneller jemanden erkennen der
infektions ist und dann nimmt man ihn
aus dem infektion sprach in dem er
isoliert wird er oder sie das ist der
entscheidende punkt aber sie werden das
virus nicht weg testen sondern sie
können eine infektionsquelle schneller
erkennen
aber ich sage es nochmal einer instanz
von 100 oder 200 werden ebenso viele
tests positiv seien dass sie das
infektionsgeschehen nicht stoppen
sondern wir werden halt dann einfach
hunderttausende in die quarantäne bzw
isolierung schicken wir müssen die
inzidenz runterbringen und gerade bei b
11 7
da gibt es studien die sagen dass es 30
40 70 prozent höher ansteckend ist als
die anderen varianten ein erklärt statt
113 oder 1,7
die übertragung ist so rasch und
intensiv sie können dieses virus nicht
weg testen
die nächste frau kollegin angelika
slavik von der süddeutschen zeitung
ich wüsste gerne herr minister mit den
vektor impfstoffen ja ich weiss ist
jetzt mal zusammen ständig nur ärger hat
es dann konsequenzen für die künftige
impfstoff bestellung ist es überhaupt
möglich konsequenzen daraus zu ziehen
also können sie in zukunft sagen wir
bestellen nur mal bleibt bei antec weil
wir haben keine nebenwirkungen und
liefern immer pünktlich am montag und
eine medizinische frage dieser diese
aussetzung von regiebetrieben
krankenhaus und wie lang kann wieder
muss die dann anhalten und können sie in
dem zusammenhang was sagen zur
tätlichkeit der variante b 17 ist es
gibt zahlen dazu dass die wirklich
erhöht die sind verkleidet waren jetzt
schon drei fragen die mit den
impfstoffen gegen grund ansatz den wir
hatten und immer noch haben nämlich
nicht nur auf einen einzigen hersteller
und eine einzige technologie zu setzen
der macht aus meiner sicht auch für die
zukunft sind wir haben mit dem m rna
technologie sehr gute erfahrungen bis
hierhin sehr gute ergebnisse was
wirksamkeit angeht was wirkungen und
nebenwirkungen oder nicht nebenwirkungen
angeht was eine mögliche anpassung auch
amputationen angeht sind noch nicht
erfolgt aber nach dem was man erwarten
darf was da gelingen kann deswegen ist
es aus meiner sicht richtig und
vernünftig und so als die eu kommission
hier auch angekündigt dass wir gemeinsam
in europa sehr stark auch weiterhin auf
m rna technologien setzen
aber wir haben zb tod impfstoff bis
jetzt noch gar nicht im portfolio und es
kann eben situationen geben wo auch der
in entsprechenden unterschied machen
kann und gerade weil wir noch nicht
wissen welche wirkungen und
nebenwirkungen auch mit anderen
impfstoffen auftauchen können werden wir
weiterhin auch auf ein portfolio setzen
das jetzt nicht nur auf einen hersteller
und nur auf eine technologie am ende
setzt den schwerpunkt allerdings bei m
rna zu setzen das finde ich auch den
erfahrungen der letzten monate auf jeden
fall vernünftig der kollege leif hat
fragte bilardo vielleicht sage ich
einfach mal was sie hat ihn gefragt wie
lange kann man einfach die priorisierung
eigentlich und aussetzen von von
normalprogramm eigentlich aufrecht
halten das ist eine sehr berechtigte
fragen und natürlich ist das auch nur im
moment ein mittel zum zweck um diese
menge von patienten überhaupt bewältigen
zu können
auch das können wir überhaupt gar nicht
unendlich sozusagen auswählen das ist
aber auch ein ganz starkes argument
dafür dass wir jetzt alles daran setzen
müssen die instanzen runterzukommen
beispielsweise waren wir das ist uns ja
zur jahreswende gelungen januar/februar
da ist sozusagen die anzahl der
intensivpatienten auch deutlich
zurückgegangen das hat auch dazu geführt
dass wir wieder in mehr oder weniger
nicht vollständig nicht zu 100 prozent
aber wieder in einen regelbetrieb
zurückkommen konnten dann auch die
patientin wie ersparen vorhin sagte die
auf ihrer operation war ein berechtigter
weise die versorgt werden müssen dann
versorgen konnten
das ist auch ein mittel aktuell ohne
dass es nicht geht weil wir schlichtweg
einfach auch die den platz und das
personal brauchen um die um die jetzt
diese anfallende menge von patienten
behandelt zu werden aber auch das muss
man sollte man so kurz wie möglich
halten und dabei hilft das drücken der
inzidenz die tätlichkeit von 1
einschieben wollte ich nach essen nach
den tätigkeiten ja also darüber gibt es
offensichtlich zurzeit keine klaren
daten die ersten daten die aus den
vereinigten königreich gekommen sind
waren daten die von hospitalisierten
patienten aus gingen und dort war
deutlich erhöhte tätigkeit sozusagen
jetzt gibt es zwei studien die anders
gelagert sind und die diese unterschied
nicht sehen
diese beiden studien haben auch im
studiendesign gewisse schwächen
die frage wie bei der einen studie wie
die patienten rekrutiert worden ist
nicht so ganz überzeugen ist
offensichtlich eine offene frage hoffen
wir dass es nicht so ist wäre schön wenn
die variante nur höher an strecken wer
und keine höhere krankheitslast ist aber
die frage ist momentan nicht eindeutig
zu bauen dann jetzt die frage vom
kollegen leifert an herrn wieder sie
haben vor einem jahr im märz 2020
empfohlen die intensivbetten kapazität
von 28 auf 56.000 zu verdoppeln
warum geraten wir jetzt mit 6000
intensivpatienten an unser limit wo sind
die anderen 20 tausend betten und den
vor einem jahr noch die rede das kann ja
über carstens besser weil das beantworte
ich gerne also 56.000 intensivbetten ich
meinen deutschland ist bekannt dafür
dass wir internationalen vergleich
wirklich viel intensivbetten aber 56.000
intensivbetten die die gibt es nicht die
können ja auf der seite der die wir
reportieren dass wir ich bin ja auch als
wissenschaftlicher leiter
mitverantwortlich für das die wir
intensiv register wir haben die klare
mittlerweile und das haben wir seit
einem jahr eben jetzt eine klare
übersicht über das was wir erbeten haben
das sind aktuell betreibt ware 24 und
wir haben dann eine notfallreserve die
vielleicht noch mal hier sozusagen 8000
patienten 8000 betten betreibt die man
gegebenfalls dazu schalten könnte das
ist sozusagen das was rein anzahl und
vorhanden ist
aber nochmal ich habe das vorhin schon
gesagt wenn sie diese notfallreserven
betreiben wollen es nützt ihnen wirklich
nichts dass sie im bett haben im raum
haben beatmungsgerät haben und monitor
haben und patient darin liegt aber sie
haben keine menschen die diesen
patienten versorgen
eine versorgung in diesen dann
zusätzlich geschaffenen bereichen ist
tatsächlich nur dann möglich wenn wir
krank in anderen bereichen stationen
herunterfahren personal umschifften
sozusagen auch in die intensiv medizin
im sinne eines qualifikations nächstes
ich erinnere nur daran dass wir in der
hoch-zeit in jetzt im zum jahreswechsel
hatten den medizinstudenten die in die
praktisch an der patientenversorgung als
pflegekräfte
gehabt haben wir haben resistenz ärzte
gehabt die dort nun auch die
pflegeversorgung gemacht haben damit man
um dann schlecht schlichtweg auch
zusätzlich aufgebaute kapazitäten
betreiben kann und auch das ist ganz
klar das ist dass das kompliment was wir
zur verfügung haben ist endlich
wenn sie das versteht sich von selbst
wenn die wenn wir die qualifikation der
menschen die vor ort die
patientenversorgung bis ins unendliche
verdünnen und das käme daten dann
tatsächlich wenn wir 6000 zusätzliche
intensivbetten schaffen würden dann
verdienen wir auch die qualität von
therapie und behandlung die jeder
einzelne patient bekommen kann
auch das von daher ist sozusagen das
schlichtweg eine realistische maßnahmen
und das auch das wollten wir vermeiden
auch im sinne einer qualitativ hoch
versorgung und endlich weiter die
intensivbetten kapazitäten außerdem
deswegen noch mal an der stelle wir
brauchen mit kontrolle von incident sind
damit diese intensivstation die
kapazitäten die wir haben eben nicht
überlastet werden
bin im übrigen auch sicher und der
anspannung aller ressourcen könnten wir
sicherlich noch mal vielleicht sogar
einige tausend patienten behandeln die
frage ist wie erwachsen skat sagt unter
welchen bedingungen weil die frage wie
das ergebnis der behandlung ist gerade
bei coop mit 19 unter beratung viel
davon zu tun damit zu tun mit welcher
expertise und welchen zeitlichen und
aufmerksamkeits ressourcen pflege da
arbeiten kann und ich verstehen manchmal
auch die logik dahinter nicht dass man
sozusagen es einige immer so austesten
wollen was das system noch so kann ja
vielleicht schaffen wir es vielleicht
wenn wir schaffen eine gewisse zeit 10
oder 15.000 kurbel 19 patienten zu
behandeln und dann sehr erschwerten wie
sie sagten verbundenen bedingungen
sozusagen
aber was ist denn die logik dahinter
also sozusagen zu warten auszutesten der
kollaps erreicht ist gleichzeitig
pflegekräfte ärzte alle verschleißen
damit anschließend überhaupt keiner mehr
in den in den in den krankenhäusern
arbeitet und mit jedem patienten und
seinen angehörigen auch noch viel leid
in kauf genommen zu haben
y co wird ist reden immer auch
richtigerweise über die todeszahlen und
dann mal schauen was der anderen
situation passiert und deswegen kann ich
mit der dem ansatz sozusagen wenn man
eine bestimmte zahl von betten hat kann
man ja erstmal die voll werden lassen
konnte ich schon in den letzten monaten
nie was anfangen das kann ich auch jetzt
nicht
vielleicht darf ich noch ergänzen wir
haben das im übrigen in anderen ländern
gesehen wie es ist wenn es zwar
irgendwie ein beatmungsgerät gibt aber
nicht das qualifizierte personal die
diesen patienten versorgen kann und das
ist etwas was uns in deutschland im
moment erspart geblieben ist und ich
glaube wir müssen alles daran setzen
dass wir das so erhalten die nächste
frage ja pakistan ist von der idee ich
habe eine frage an sie herr spahn
sie haben ja gerade gesagt in der korona
krise stehen die pflegekräfte noch mehr
feuer als sonst sie wollen höhere löhne
für die pflegekräfte mehr geld für die
häusliche pflege brauchen dafür aber
eine pflege bevorsteht diese pflege
reform noch in dieser legislaturperiode
kommen zuerst einmal die pflegereform
die sie ansprechen da geht es um die
stationäre altenpflege nicht um die
situation in den kliniken und übrigens
zeigt gerade die kliniken haben
tarifverträge und die bezahlung ist
jetzt mit zuschlägen und anderen auch
klar mehr geht immer aber schon auch
eine die die da ist das thema ist ja
nicht bezahlung hier und im übrigen
nicht tarifverträge das thema ist die
enorme arbeitsbelastung in einer nicht
selten jahr sieben tage woche 24 stunden
betrieb und dann auch jetzt in der
intensiv so belastet und deswegen ist
das eine thema die bezahlung aber ich
werde auch sehr dafür auch bei den
gewerkschaften das nicht darauf zu
reduzieren weil das alleine löst das
nicht so ist eine frage der
arbeitsbedingungen insgesamt der
personalbemessung und wir sind weiter in
gesprächen mit den koalitionsfraktionen
um zu schauen welche teile ich würde sie
lieber gestern als morgen machen welche
teile auch in der stationären
altenpflege wir umsetzen können von den
gemachten reformvorschlägen die auch die
arbeitsbedingungen und auch die tarife
zahlungsbedingungen in der altenpflege
verbessern ich finde wichtig dass das
jetzt nicht durcheinander geht das ist
altenpflege und hier geht es um die
pläne sind wir fast am ende die letzte
frage noch rinke ich habe wieder nicht
geschafft alle fragen abzuarbeiten
aber ihr ist danke noch eine frage an
den spanier zu medikamenten über die wir
jetzt gar nicht gesprungen haben bei der
krebsbehandlung es gibt ja einige
medikamente regeneron ist zum beispiel
so 1 was in den usa jetzt wohl relativ
erfolgreich mit notfall zulassungen
eingesetzt wird
was es hier zu erwarten wird zum
beispiel dieses medikament auch hier mit
einer notfall zulassung und dann
akzeptiert werden das medikament ist in
deutschland schon im einsatz wir haben
noch sehr versuchen der modellversuche
würde ich jetzt nicht nennen
es ist keine zulassung aber das ist wir
haben diese wir haben diese wir haben
wir ja auch unter den einsatz genommen
mit entsprechenden empfehlungen der
zulassungsbehörde sozusagen für welche
situation der arbeiter mit den
fachgesellschaften
das haben wir für die monoklonalen
antikörper um die es hier geht
auch von dem hersteller und dem sie
gerade angesprochen haben und was gerade
in der finalen abstimmung ist es auch
nochmal eine verordnung die klar stellt
die vergütung weil im moment sehen wir
dass wir die antikörper haben sie aber
aus meiner sicht noch deutlich mehr zum
einsatz kommen müssten
die herausforderung dabei ist wenn sie
in der klinik schon sinn es ist zu spät
sie müssen die sehr früh nach
infektionen geben den patientinnen und
patienten die mit hoher
wahrscheinlichkeit das muss man dann
abschätzen
bis mittlerweile urintest und anderes
für oder ärztlich abschätzen werden mit
einer hohen wahrscheinlichkeit ein
risiko für einen schweren oder
schwersten verlauf hat der sollte und
der ärztliche entscheidung nach den
empfehlungen die auch die
fachgesellschaften erarbeitet haben
dieses medikament bekommen und jetzt ist
die herausforderung es ist keine
tablette sondern eine infusion und im
zweifel sollte der arzt und oder
medizinisches personal
es dauert 3 45 stunden dabei sein und
dieser aufwand braucht natürlich eine
entsprechende vergütung
es sollte es da gibt es noch andere
facetten und das bilden wir gerade auch
ab in einer entsprechenden verordnung
also kurze antwort ist das medikament
ist in deutschland verfügbar
wir müssen es jetzt nur noch auch viel
viel stärker und wollen das auch und
arbeiten daran in die fläche bringen
weil es natürlich nur ein unterschied
macht wenn es auch zur anwendung kommen
und nicht nur verfügbar ist dann sind
wir am ende angelangt die korona stunde
ist vorbei ich bedanke mich ganz
herzlich bei unseren gästen professor
weber grafen professor wieder ersparen
schön dank